Welcome to the deep dive, where
we take your source material and
really try to unearth the most
potent insights, cutting through
the noise to get to what truly
matters.
Today, we're diving into a
document titledfoo.pdf, which
stands for that phrase F around
and find out, right?
It's a pretty stark, unvarnished
look at conflict by Chris
Abraham, a writer known for his,
well, incisive analysis of
societal dynamics.
And specifically, we're looking
at excerpts provocatively titled
Faifo, when the Speech Stops
Saving You.
And this isn't, you know, a
typical exploration of policy or
history or even specific current
events like we might usually
tackle.
Our mission today really is to
unpack a deeply unsettling, yet
I think undeniably crucial
perspective on the nature of
real world confrontation.
This document, it just strips
away popular misconceptions
about how conflict unfolds, and
in doing that, it serves as a
stark warning.
A warning, yeah.
So we'll be extracting crucial
lessons about, well, the true
cost of violence and confronting
the dangerous illusions many
people hold illusions about
their own safety, about the
rules of engagement, things like
that.
That's right.
So if you've ever found yourself
thinking about confrontations,
maybe it's online arguments
escalating, or just the abstract
idea of physical conflict, or
even, you know, wondering about
the rules of engagement in a
protest setting, this deep dive
is going to fundamentally
challenge some deeply held
assumptions.
Assumptions you might not even
realize you have.
Exactly.
It's a very direct, very raw,
almost brutal look at a reality
we often prefer to ignore.
A reality that, according to
this, prioritizes outcome over
intent or rhetoric.
So let's unpack this.
Let's do it.
So the author, Chris Abraham, he
starts by making it incredibly
clear what this document isn't.
He's very explicit, says it's
not a call to arms.
It's not an endorsement of
violence and certainly not an
attempt to, you know,
sensationalize bloodshed for
entertainment.
He's very deliberate about
disclaiming those
interpretations.
Yeah, he puts that right up
front.
So if it avoids all of those
things, what is its core purpose
then?
What's it trying to achieve for
the reader?
Well, what's truly fascinating
here, I think, is that the
document is presented purely as
a warning, almost like a
dispassionate analysis of
inevitable consequences.
Okay, It seems written for
people who fundamentally
misunderstand the nature of real
world confrontation.
Maybe those who believe it
behaves like I don't know the
debates they have online or
arguments in a dorm room.
Right.
Or even protests.
Or even structured, often kind
of theatrical protests where the
worst outcomes are typically,
you know, minor injuries, A
scuffle, maybe legal citations.
The core message is a direct,
unyielding challenge to the very
idea that there's always time
for rhetoric, or that sheer
force of will, or loud yelling,
or filming something for social
media.
Or having a moral high ground.
Exactly that.
Any of that can somehow overcome
a direct physical threat.
It's really about tearing down
the psychological comfort we
often get from viewing
confrontation through a kind of
ceremonial lens.
Ceremonial meaning like their
rules.
Yeah, where words or moral
stances or even legal frameworks
are seen as powerful Shields
somehow immune to physical
reality, it's incredibly
difficult for us as humans to
truly grasp the utterly
unscripted, chaotic, and often
brutal nature of true violence.
Why is that so hard to grasp, do
you think?
Well, partly because our minds
naturally try to impose order
and narrative even on disorder,
right?
We're used to a world with
rules, even unspoken ones, in
conflict, and this document
basically says those rules just
vanish in real world
confrontations.
This psychological tendency it's
often linked to normalcy bias,
our inclination to underestimate
disaster and assume things will
just go back to normal quickly.
Right, assuming the script will
play out.
Exactly.
And that can be incredibly
dangerous.
We project a script onto
situations that have.
None.
The stakes, Wow.
They're immediately made
terrifyingly clear.
Abraham doesn't pull any
punches, does he?
Not at all.
He goes straight to funerals
right from the beginning.
It's a it's quite a shocking
opening it.
Is, and you have to ask why such
a grim prediction right from the
start?
I think the author's intent is
clearly to under score the
irreversible nature of what he
suggests is coming.
These aren't abstract deaths
happening somewhere else, easily
forgotten.
Right.
Not statistics on a news report,
no.
He talks about bodies in
American streets and farm fields
and alleyways.
It's meant to be stark,
localized, incredibly personal,
a warning designed to make the
consequences feel immediate and
visceral.
And he uses that analogy, which
is pretty jarring, about the
West Bank settlers.
Yes, it is jarring, but it's
used to drive the point home
about a lived reality that,
while maybe distant from many of
us, is deeply relevant to his
thesis.
How so?
Well, he presents these settlers
as people who, According to him,
have understood this brutal
reality for generations.
They live every single day on
the edge of what one side calls
a homeland and another side
calls a theft.
Living right on that edge.
Exactly.
Existing on the very verge of a
killing that, as he puts it,
changes the neighborhood
forever.
This isn't just abstract
conflict theory, it's about the
immediate, tangible and
permanent altering of the social
fabric.
And connecting that to the
bigger picture, what's the
implication?
Well, it implies A terrifying
breakdown of the social
contracts, the norms that
usually govern peaceful
interaction in a society.
The document warns starkly that
once that boundary is crossed,
it does not return to normal.
The dead do not come back.
The habits of restraint do not
rebuild overnight.
That suggests a permanent
societal shift, a scar that
fundamentally alters how people
interact.
Turning what we think of as
normal into something else
entirely.
Into a relic of the past, he
says, What's coming will feel
like something that cannot be
undone, precisely because the
concept of normalcy itself has
been obliterated by the reality
of death.
OK, moving on to this section,
provocatively titled There Was
No Ceremony in Violence.
This really zeroes in on one of
the most, I think, insidious and
dangerous illusions.
We might hold the idea that
there's some kind of invisible
line in a confrontation.
You know, a moment for heroics,
or a chance to deliver that
powerful speech, or like a final
monologue before something
really bad happens.
Exactly.
We as humans, we seem deeply
ingrained with this need for
narrative, for structure, for
dramatic arc in things.
Right, like a movie scene.
Yeah.
So people often imagine this
kind of theatrical duel, a
moment where they can show their
courage or deliver their lines,
make a stand or square up to
make threats.
Maybe pull out their phone and
filled it?
Right believing they can buy
themselves a few moments to
stand tall, maybe film it for
posterity or proof of their
moral rightness.
But the document just directly,
almost violently debunks this.
How does?
It put it it says real violence,
the kind that ends lives, the
kind that leaves blood on
concrete and wakes you up in the
night for years afterward, does
not give you that line.
And this speaks to a fundamental
cognitive bias, doesn't it?
Often called the fairness bias
or maybe optimism bias, we
subconsciously expect a fair
fight or some kind of warning.
Or we think bad things won't
happen to us.
Precisely.
It's this desire for control and
predictability where the author
argues none exists.
We project our internal sense of
justice onto an external world
that might operate very
differently.
And that.
Tendency can be fatal.
That's the argument, a fatal
flaw in genuine confrontations.
The imagery used is so stark.
The time you spend explaining
how brave you are is time the
other person may spend moving to
end you.
Chilling.
It paints this picture of brutal
efficiency, immediacy.
Yeah, where words are not just
useless, but actually
detrimental to your survival.
They become a luxury you simply
cannot afford in that moment.
And this brings us back to that
that striking example from the
West Bank settlers again, but
this time focusing on how they
embody this lack of ceremony,
this absence of that invisible
line, right?
And what's fascinating here is
the practical, lived reality he
presents as a stark contrast to
our common misconceptions go on
in places like Israel and the
West Bank, the document
explains.
These civilian settlers, though
technically not military, often
have years of IDF.
That's Israel Defense Forces
Service.
Right, military service.
They've done time on
checkpoints, been on patrols.
They have, as he puts it, learn
what it means to look into
another man's face and pull a
trigger before he does it first.
So it's not theoretical for
them.
Not at all.
It's a deeply ingrained, almost
primal understanding of
immediate, decisive action born
from repeated high stakes
experience, and the critical
difference highlighted is their
profound lack of hesitation.
They don't wait.
They are not waiting for a
verbal exchange or a
philosophical debate about land
and rights, the document
emphasizes.
They do not wait for you to
finish your sentence about land
and law.
That's direct.
Very.
If you walk on onto their hill
with a slogan and a camera, they
will not give you a second
chance if they believe you are a
threat.
And then this line, there is no
structure to hold them back, no
leash to snap.
Wow.
It is not fair and it is not
complicated.
It just is.
It just illustrates this concept
of preemption in a survival
situation where the cost of
hesitation is absolute.
So the argument is that waiting
for words, expecting some
process.
It's a luxury unavailable in
real threats.
And this raises that important
question for us.
Are you listening?
How does our ingrained
expectation of fairness or
process shaped by our relatively
peaceful societies?
How does that blind us?
Yeah.
How does it blind us to
immediate danger, make us
profoundly vulnerable when those
rules simply don't apply, and
when we encounter people who
operate entirely without them?
OK, so we've explored the raw,
unscripted nature of individual
violence.
Now the author turns his focus
to something many of us probably
take for granted, the assumed
restraint of the state itself,
right?
Abraham highlights this common
belief, especially America, that
the state, you know, with its
armored vests, military trucks,
will always choose caution,
always choose restraint, even
when provoked.
He calls it the illusion of the
bubble.
It's a profound point and it it
really rings true, doesn't it?
People often assume that agents
behind the glass, the uniformed
figures, are inherently
constrained.
By rules.
By protocol.
Yeah, by some sort of moral code
or protocol that makes them less
likely to use legal force, that
they're somehow on a short
leash, always accountable.
And the document concedes, for
now, that is mostly true.
Mostly true.
It even gives compelling
examples of what it calls
remarkable restraint.
Think about IC agents in full
gear, tolerating being screamed
at.
Filmed.
We've seen those videos.
Or federal agents in urban
riots, showing, as he puts it,
more restraint than any other
country's paramilitaries would.
Standing there, enduring stones,
fireworks, even direct assault,
holding the line.
Why?
Why do they hold the line?
Because, the document argues,
they know that the moment they
open fire, it all changes.
They understand the profound
societal consequences of that
shift, the loss of legitimacy,
the escalation.
That bubble of restraint, it's
not about morals.
Not according to this analysis.
It's attributed to fear.
It exists only because they fear
what happens if they lose
control.
It's presented not as a virtue,
but as a strategic calculation
of consequences, a fragile
deterrent.
Like institutional self
preservation?
Exactly.
Think about those protest scenes
we've all witnessed where,
despite intense provocation, law
enforcement holds their line.
That's the bubble in action, a
calculated balancing act between
order and avoiding irreversible
breakdown.
OK, so the state's restraint is
calculated.
It's based on fear of
consequences, not some innate
code.
But the core of this section is
really chilling, warning that
this discipline, this restraint,
it's not guaranteed.
No, not at all.
When does that leash disappear?
What's the tipping point that
pops this bubble?
Well, the document states it
pretty clearly.
The moment the agents decide
that fear is smaller than the
danger, they see that's the key
phrase.
Fear smaller than the danger,
yeah.
For example, the moment someone
kills one of them, or fires
back, or breaks the unspoken
rule that the fight is
ceremonial, that restraint
vanishes instantly.
The.
Calculation change.
The calculation changes
completely.
The perceived consequences of
action suddenly seem less
daunting than the perceived
consequences of inaction.
It shifts from, you know, a
deterrent posture to an
operational 1.
And the author uses some vivid
imagery here.
He does the armored plates, the
rifles, the extra magazines, the
training for urban combat.
All of it shifts from display to
function.
It's no longer about showing
force, it becomes about using
force.
Active unbridled combat.
To survive, to neutralize the
threat.
Right.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, it suggests this
profound societal
transformation, a point of no
return, where the state's role
moves from maintaining order to
engaging in direct, unrestrained
conflict with its own citizens.
That's terrifying.
It is.
The document ominously predicts
that when that happens, there
will be funerals for protesters,
for agents, for bystanders.
And it pushes back against the
idea of filming for a cause in
that moment.
Brutally so.
It says there will be cameras,
but the footage will not be
about your courage.
It will be evidence for next
time and it will not stop the
next time from happening.
So the documentation and just
becomes part of the cycle, yeah.
Rather than a means to stop it,
just providing material for
analysis in a world that's lost
its bubble.
That's a powerful and deeply
unsettling thought.
Now, one of the most critical
warnings for me personally is
captured in this idea that you
cannot read a life at a glance.
It speaks to a fundamental and
often fatal human error in
judgement, especially when
facing a confrontation.
What makes this mistake so
common and, well, so dangerous
according to Abraham?
Well, it's a critical insight,
isn't it?
That human tendency to misread
situations.
The document states the greatest
error.
The most dangerous assumption is
assuming they can read who they
are facing.
Believing you can size someone
up instantly.
Exactly.
Believing you can perceive
weakness or cowardice or
inexperience in another person
just by looking at them, or
maybe by their initial reaction.
It's a profound misjudgment of
capabilities based purely on
superficial cues.
Why do we do that?
Well, it seems rooted deeply in
our tendency to project biases
and assumptions onto others,
especially under stress.
We instinctively look for cues
that confirm our existing
beliefs about how conflict it
should play out, how people
should behave.
Using mental shortcuts.
Exactly.
Heuristics.
And in moments of confrontation,
these shortcuts can be
tragically wrong.
The document really emphasizes
the unseen elements that
determine capabilities.
It says, but you do not know
what the other person knows.
You do not know what they have
lived through.
rehearsed in their mind.
It's a powerful reminder that
outward appearances are
preconceived notions, even an
initial lack of aggression.
It means nothing.
Precisely nothing.
When confronted with someone's
true, often hidden capabilities
for violence, the quietest
person might in fact be the most
lethal.
And it warns,
counterintuitively, that those
who look the least threatening
might actually be the most
dangerous.
That seems to go against our
instincts.
It does.
We often assume danger looks a
certain way.
Loud, aggressive, physically
imposing.
But the author suggests
something different about the
kind of training that makes
someone quietly terrifying.
It redefines our understanding
of what a threat looks like.
How so?
Well, the document explicitly
states, many of the people who
look the least threatening are
the ones you should fear the
most.
These individuals, he suggests,
aren't looking for a fight.
They're not seeking conflict or
attention or an audience.
They're often quiet, unassuming.
Right.
But the document warns, if the
fight is brought to them, they
do not wait.
What makes them so dangerous,
according to this, is that
they've undergone real training.
Real training versus.
Versus what the author calls the
staged kind, not the
performative kind.
This implies A deeply ingrained,
almost automatic response burned
in through rigorous, practical,
maybe even traumatic experience.
It ensures they don't hesitate
it.
Bypasses conscious thought.
That's the implication.
It's not about looking tough.
We're giving a speech.
It's about efficiency and
decisive action, a conditioned
response.
And the document drives this
home with graphic detail.
Once that switches flip, there
is no speech.
No monologue.
No monologue, no handshake, just
three seconds or less and one of
you does not stand up again.
Wow, that paints a stark picture
of unceremonial violence devoid
of any homic Hollywood stuff.
Completely.
And it points directly to the
danger of relying on visual cues
and stereotypes and assessing a
threat.
The document suggests true
danger often lies in the
unexpected, the quiet person who
simply prepared.
Prepared through drilling
reactions until they're
instinctual.
Right.
Rather than the person who is
overtly aggressive or loud, it's
a warning to look past the
surface, to recognize that
competence and conflict is
rarely theatrical.
OK, the document then shifts to
the cost, and it frames
confrontation not just as a
physical danger, but as a a
perilous gamble.
Yes.
What are people betting their
lives on in these scenarios,
according to Abraham?
And why are these bets so
precarious?
This is a crucial point because
it makes the abstract incredibly
personal and immediate.
It quantifies the stakes.
The document lays out two
primary, very precarious bets.
What's the first one?
1st if you provoke A trained
unit, say state agents in their
armor, you are betting your life
on their fear of the
consequences.
Betting on their institutional
calculus.
Exactly.
You're assuming their fear of
public backlash, legal
repercussions, political fallout
from using lethal force.
You're assuming that will always
outweigh the immediate danger
they perceive from you.
Banking on their leash holding
right.
On their internal discipline.
The second bet, equally
precarious, arises if you face a
civilian in what he calls the
fog of war, someone with no
leash and no master to answer
to.
What are you betting on them?
In that scenario, you're betting
on the hope that they will see
you as less than a threat.
You're relying entirely on their
subjective perception, their
judgement of your intentions and
capabilities, or maybe just
their own personal unproven
restraint.
This is where misreading someone
becomes fatal.
Precisely because you're betting
that your performance of protest
or defiance will be interpreted
as non lethal, even if your
actions are provocative.
But the underlying message is
stark.
These are not sustainable bets.
Not forever.
No, the document explicitly
warns these are not bets that
pay off forever.
One day, somewhere, the
calculation changes.
Someone flinches.
Someone pulls the trigger.
It emphasizes the statistical
inevitability.
Yeah, the inevitability of
failure when boundaries are
constantly pushed, when these
fragile assumptions are tested
time and again.
It's a sobering reminder that
even if you win 100 times, the
one time you lose the cost is
absolute.
The odds eventually catch up.
And the cost?
It isn't just to the individual
directly involved, is it?
It ripples out, expands, takes
on a broader societal dimension.
That's a critical piece of the
argument, absolutely.
Connecting this to the bigger
picture, the document makes it
painfully clear the consequences
extend far beyond the immediate
participants.
How does it frame the personal
cost?
Profoundly and permanently.
That is how you will lose
friends, or your child, or your
father.
It's deeply intimate, a familiar
familial tragedy.
But then it broadens out.
Yes, it speaks to the broader
societal impact, describing how
collective action or a cause
gets fundamentally transformed,
maybe even diminished, by this
escalating cost.
That is how A cause turns into a
list of names read over candles
in a park.
That image.
Candles in a park.
It's a stark, tangible
representation of memorializing
lost lives.
A grim alternative to achieving
goals.
Exactly the physical
manifestation of failure, of
hopes extinguish a permanent
memorial to sacrifice, perhaps
without victory.
And then the document reiterates
that chilling theme we've heard
before.
Irreversibility.
Yes, and once it starts it does
not go back.
It underscores the self
perpetuating nature of violence.
It implies a deep societal scar,
1 not easily healed, suggesting
that when a community crosses
this threshold, returning to
previous norms of peace,
civility, restraint, it becomes
incredibly difficult, maybe
impossible.
It creates a new, harsher
reality.
And one that fundamentally
reshapes the future.
Yeah, OK.
This next section, The Deaths we
learn to ignore it, opens with
that really chilling quote often
attributed to Stalin or Lenin.
A single death is a tragedy.
1,000,000 deaths is a statistic.
It's just perfectly encapsulates
the desensitization process the
author describes.
It does, and the document states
quite plainly the credit does
not matter.
It is true.
It then elaborates on how this
profound and disturbing
transformation occurs.
It illustrates that chilling
process of human desensitization
to suffering.
How does it start?
In the beginning, each death is
felt.
The first protester killed by an
agent's bullet that will
dominate headlines for days,
trigger widespread outrage,
grief across the nation.
Similarly, the first IC officer
shot resisting a raid.
Front page news, widespread
mourning, promises it must never
happen again.
This initial response reflects
our natural empathy, our
recognition of individual human
loss.
But, the document explains, if
the violence continues, if the
cycle of killing grows, the
shock does not.
And this is the crucial point.
It speaks to that psychological
phenomenon, emotional
desensitization or compassion
fatigue.
How does the mind cope?
Well, how does it cope with
overwhelming tragedy with a
seemingly endless stream of
loss?
It abstracts.
It turns it into something less
personal, less emotionally
taxing.
It's a survival mechanism in a
way.
Protecting itself.
Yeah, protecting the mind from
being constantly overwhelmed by
grief and horror.
But it comes in a profound
societal cost, as the value of
individual life diminishes in
our collective perception,
reducing human beings to
numbers.
So the initial shock fades.
The news coverage shrinks.
The funerals just blur into one
indistinguishable mass.
It becomes routine background
noise.
Exactly.
The document cants a stark
picture of this progression.
The coverage shrinks, the
funerals blur together.
What once felt intolerable
becomes routine.
And the author argues, we see it
already, perhaps unconsciously.
What examples does he give?
Really powerful contemporary
examples.
Shootings in American cities
that once would paralyze a block
with grief now run on the ticker
at the bottom of the hour.
The frequency makes them less
impactful.
Just another data point.
Gaza's dead are buried by the
dozen.
That rapid, overwhelming scale
of loss becomes impossible to
process individually, leading to
an abstraction of suffering.
And Ukraine?
And then the poignant
observation that really hits
home for many.
The front lines in Ukraine used
to draw open mouths on
television, gripping the world.
Now they roll by like weather.
At a weather report, devastating
comparison.
It is.
The human mind adapts.
It has to to survive such
sustained exposure to tragedy.
People adapt.
It is the minds way to survive.
But this adaptation comes at a
profound existential cost.
Every new death after the first
100 is just a mark on a board.
So it raises that uncomfortable
question, what happens to the
meaning of a life or a 'cause
when deaths just become data
points?
Right, and the document offers
this grim, almost cynical
counter narrative to any
romanticized ideas about
martyrdom.
The ones who go out looking for
the fight believe they will be
remembered.
Many will not be.
Why not?
The 'cause that felt so enormous
at the first funeral will slip
under the pile of normalcy that
comes with time.
Connecting this to the bigger
picture, it suggests that
prolonged low level conflict
drains meaning from human life,
from the underlying causes,
leading to a cynical detached
society where even death loses
its impact.
Where empathy erodes.
And the cycle of violence just
feeds on indifference becomes
self perpetuating.
So after all of this incredibly
unsettling analysis, what's the
ultimate, unavoidable lesson?
When the slogans fade, the moral
arguments fail, the bubble of
civility breaks for good.
What does Abraham conclude under
Why this matters?
Well, the document concludes
with a really unambiguous,
chilling statement that just
cuts through everything else.
If there is a lesson left when
the slogans fade and the bubble
breaks, it is this.
There is no speech strong enough
to hold back what happens once
the first blood runs.
Words become meaningless.
Utterly meaningless, it
emphasizes the absolute
supremacy of physical action
over verbal protest or ideology.
In those moments of direct,
lethal confrontation, words are
a luxury that has ceased to
exist.
And there's a follow up.
Yeah, a truly chilling follow up
that speaks directly to that
normalization of death we just
discussed.
And there is no guarantee that
the deaths that follow will stay
precious to the people who
watched you die.
Wow, it touches on the fleeting
nature of empathy.
Exactly.
When numbers are small, they're
tragedies.
When they grow, they become
statistics, losing their
individual weight, their power
to move people.
The mind moves on because it has
to, but the fighting doesn't.
The initial shock evaporates,
leaving only the grim reality of
more funerals.
OK, so for those listening for
you, what's the single most
important thing to take away
from this incredibly sobering,
yet I think vital deep dive into
Abraham's warnings?
What actionable insight should
we carry forward?
The document provides very
direct, very unequivocal advice
under the heading.
If you take anything from this,
it states that those who survive
real violence, those who've
actually experienced it and
lived, they understand one
fundamental truth, which is if
you were going to stand your
ground, you must know that there
is no script, no opening
ceremony.
There is no fairness, no pause,
no referee.
It just hammers home that
unvarnished, brutal reality of
conflict dispels any lingering
illusions about a fair fight.
And then it offers advice.
Yes, its core piece of advice,
almost a plea for self
preservation.
It is always better to avoid the
fight altogether.
That's presented as the ultimate
wisdom for survival de
escalation, disengagement as the
primary, most reliable path to
safety.
But if avoidance isn't possible,
if you must, stand your ground.
Then the document brutally
clarifies the mechanics of
survival, because once it
starts, the winner is usually
the one who moves first without
giving you the chance to finish
your threat.
Move. 1st And if you are the one
who hesitates because you
thought you had more time, you
will not get a second chance.
It highlights the brutal
efficiency of pre emptive action
when a threat is undeniably
present and lethal, reinforcing
that idea.
In true confrontation,
hesitation is a death sentence.
It wraps up with a truly
unsettling, yet profoundly
important final warning.
It feels like a direct address
to each of us listening.
The final lines are just a stark
summary of the entire piece,
reinforcing that central thesis.
We can pretend that is not how
it works.
We can pretend that words win
over fear and blood.
But the grave does not care
about your speech.
An undeniable truth stripped of
all comfort.
Completely.
And the concluding wish.
May you never have to find out
the hard way.
May you know when to walk away.
May you know when the bubble is
gone, and know that there is no
speech that will bring it back
once it is that serves as this
potent personal Cle directly to
you, the listener.
Underscoring the ultimate cost
of misunderstanding.
Yes, the cost of
misunderstanding this brutal
reality of violence, which
utterly transcends words or
ideology connecting to the
bigger picture.
That phrase may you know when to
walk away, is the most direct
advice offered.
It suggests disengagement is the
only reliable path to safety in
these dire scenarios.
Because once that line is
crossed.
Once that boundary of violence
is crossed, the ability of words
to intervene, to revert the
situation to something more
civil, it's completely,
irrevocably lost.
The silence of the grave,
Abraham warns, is indifferent to
all your carefully crafted
arguments.
Wow, what a challenging yet
absolutely vital deep dive this
has been.
It's a profound shift in
perspective for anyone who may
be like me might unconsciously
assume a certain level of
civility or structure in moments
of intense confrontation.
It truly forces you to re
evaluate how you perceive
conflict, not just on the grand
scale, but maybe in every
interaction.
Indeed, this deep dive forces
us, really forces you, to
confront uncomfortable truths
about human behavior under
pressure, about the very real
fragility of social order and
the stark reality that in
certain situations, words truly
lose all power.
It's a sobering reminder that
understanding the true,
unvarnished nature of conflict
and critically knowing when to
disengage, knowing when that
bubble has popped, can be a
matter of life and death, not
just for the individual, but for
the wider community that might
get drawn into this irreversible
spiral of violence.
And desensitization.
It's about peeling back the
comforting layers.
Yeah, the layers of illusion we
construct around confrontation
and seeing the world as it truly
can be without the filters of
our expectations or hopes.
So what does this all mean for
you as you move through your
day, as you engage with the
world both online and off?
Perhaps it's a moment to reflect
on the assumptions you make
about confrontation, about the
power, or indeed the
powerlessness of words in
certain contexts, and the very
real consequences when those
assumptions be to different,
more brutal reality.
This deep dive wasn't about
telling you what to think,
obviously, but maybe about
giving you a new, perhaps
unsettling lens through which to
observe the world around you, to
truly see the stakes involved.
Something to Mull over.